hello how are you
hello i'm i'm good thank you
congratulations on this mini series you
know the thing i love as a queer
reporter
is when i see queer characters being
played by
you know queer people do you think that
was important in this
miniseries having queer people telling
queer stories
you know i think so because it
we all met all of us at the cast we met
for the first time like on the first day
for the read through for rehearsal and
it's not just because we're queer but i
think it was a big reason we clicked
instantly and we understood these
characters in a way that just
we related to them so much you know we
felt so privileged to be there
you know as queer actors playing queer
roles it's such a good opportunity
bridget where do you see yourself in
five years time i want
everything west end i want my name and
lights
big movie posters with me on them i
loved richie
there were moments where i didn't love
richie and i'm gonna be honest with you
about that um
when you were reading the script did you
ever feel angry at any times about some
of richie's actions
yeah lots of times actually i was just i
was annoyed at richie i'd get
angry at him for taking some of his
friends for granted and
you know he makes some questionable
choices but i also really loved
richie and i love him because he has
this irrepressible spirit and he makes a
lot of mistakes
but you can kind of see a lot of the
reasons why he might
have made them take away the heaviness
of the show there is
a lot of fun to it too and some of the
sex scenes are just like
like kind of blow your mind um do you
think it was important with
with that heaviness to kind of remind
people that you know
sex is fun right this is it this is what
i think the show
wanted to show so much is the joy and
the positivity and
the life and the spirit that comes to
define us just
as much as the pain and the grief you
know we and i think that was important
to show that and that for these
characters the sex is so
vital for them and it's fun and it's i
think it's beautiful to to see that
haven't got longer quick shower yeah
together yeah
here in the uk after the show aired it
almost i'm not kidding created a
national conversation about
hiv and aids and people there was a
whole range of responses and lots of
people
who lived through this time had no idea
what was going on because so much of it
happened in silence
and what i'm hoping is people it
encourages the conversation and people
really recognize and acknowledge how far
we have come
and that living with hiv now you're on
effective treatment you have a normal
normal life healthy life and and and you
know you can't pass the virus on and i
think that's
really important for people to to
acknowledge and to celebrate that
progress and i just hope that
you know and to get tested to know your
status well i think you are so talented
and you know i think it's important that
we always reflect and kind of look
back i know that you moved to london
when you were maybe 18 years old
and lived 18 to chase your dreams and
you lived in a small little flat and you
went out there and you achieved your
dreams look at you now
queer icon can i say it where i got
oh my gosh you know i think about my
younger self a lot
because i definitely struggled a lot
you know i had a lot of mental health
you know i've been very open about my
own mental health journey let's say and
i'll always
have it with me it's always like a
priority for me to like keep myself on
track
um but when i was that age i still don't
really know who i was and i just but i
felt like i had so much to say still but
i felt so like
different but i would want to say to
myself like
just hang on to that because that's
that's what in the end really does
you good like the things that make you
special or may you
you like that's invaluable like that's
the most precious thing ever like don't
let go of that
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos